thank you for coming out on a really
really unpleasant afternoon
um you've done us proud this is actually
the largest event that the Peabody has
held since covered so by numbers so give
yourselves all the pad on the back
[Applause]
really delighted to see you here I'm
Chris Norris I'm the director of public
programs at the Yale Peabody Museum and
on behalf of Yale University and the
museum I'd like to welcome you to the
inaugural John Ostrom lecture
I'd also like to take this time to
acknowledge as we sit here on Yale's
site that indigenous peoples and Nations
including the Mohegan the Mashantucket
Pequot the Eastern peacock the
scattercock the Golden Hill pagasset the
Niantic and the Quinnipiac and other
Algonquian speaking peoples have
stewarded through generations the lands
and waterways of what's now the state of
Connecticut and we honor and respect the
enduring relationship that exists
between these peoples and Nations and
this land
this is the first in a series of annual
lectures that honor the memory of John
Ostrom John was a long time curator of
vertebrate paleontology at the Peabody
Museum an outstanding paleontologist and
a man who I think it's fair to say
profoundly transformed our view of
dinosaurs and it gives me great pleasure
to introduce one of John's successors
Professor Andrew Buller faculty member
in the department of Earth and planetary
sciences and a curator of vertebrate
paleontology and vertebrate zoology at
the Peabody Museum to introduce this
this year's speaker thank you
[Applause]
to the first John Ostrom lecture
uh which I hope is a first taste of the
new Peabody which will to be opening in
early 2024 with galleries completely
redone but 50 larger than before and it
will be completely free
um we've got new mounts of just about
everything a new K-12 education center
can't wait to welcome you there
so
fossils are part of the Stony fabric of
our planet it's their component of what
we call the Rock record and in that way
they're geological
both in the compositional sense in the
sense that they're studied by geologists
but they're also part of the book of
life's history and are in that way
biologic and can be viewed through a
biological lens to be a paleontologist
to try to straddle Both Worlds often
badly you always uncomfortably
but there's some who truly Master this
OC Marsh and John Ostrom both were able
to muster their knowledge of the Living
World
to gain insight to illuminate the lives
of extinct animals
in fact I think it goes from his finest
work was his work on on the evolution of
flight which was so informed by the
behavior of living birds living bats
Ostrom had the great Insight that birds
are descended from dinosaurs and a
successor here at Yale shot Gautier
who's in the audience today showed
rigorously that birds are dinosaurs and
that the characteristics of extinct
creatures can be inferred from a
particular kind of systematic
examination of their living relatives
but no one in the modern age in my
opinion has done more for the
understanding of dinosaurs and other
extinct vertebrates as living animals
then Professor Lawrence Larry Whitmer of
Ohio University
Larry is an anatomist par excellence and
that is perhaps to me the highest
compliment one can pay a biologist for
anatomy is 3D in a 40 structure and is
the basis of everything living things
can do consider that even the twistings
and foldings of DNA are Anatomy writ
small
the hardest problems in the Life
Sciences and Medicine have to do with
biotic geometry with space and time
Larry has his bachelor's from Cornell
masters from KU PhD from Johns Hopkins
he holds the Chang Ying Chen
professorship of paleontology at Ohio
and he's published numerous
groundbreaking
I would say discipline creating papers
and all the most exclusive scientific
journalists appeared National Geographic
CNN NPR
media around the world he is uh highly
dedicated also to public education at
all levels
his scholarly work
has been a primary inspiration maybe the
primary inspiration for my own lab's
work here at Yale
and so it's with very great pleasure
that I that we give him to you for
Professor Whitmer is a living time
machine
it will bring you as close as one can
come to dinosaurs not buried in the
Earth but alive here before you once
more
Larry my friend
[Applause]
well thanks anjan I hope I can live up
to that that introduction
um it is a tremendous honor for me to be
invited to give the inaugural John H
Ostrom lecture here in the Glorious OC
Marsh
lecture hall right next to the legendary
uh Yale Peabody Museum we all can't wait
for for that to open and you should all
be thrilled that it's actually going to
be free admission that's a wonderful
thing
so um
the wonderful thing about John Ostrom is
that I actually knew John Ostrom
um I got to know him during my visits
here to the Peabody Museum
um I'd see him at conferences I took
this picture here back in 1985 when I
was a master's student at the University
of Kansas
John Ostrom has always been sort of a
hero of mine when I was growing up so it
kind of blew my mind when I would go to
a conference and he'd walk up to me and
go hi Larry I'd go like John Ostrum it
was my name and he wants me to call him
John I just couldn't quite handle that
and it turns out that we're related
at least academically
um
John Ostrom here was the um
got his uh did his PhD work under the
mentorship of Ned Colbert at the
American Museum of Natural History later
John was the PHD advisor for Peter
Dodson and later who was in turn the the
PHD advisor for Dave Weis hampel who was
my PhD advisor at Johns Hopkins Medical
School so that would make John my great
academic great grandparent
that's an amazing picture except I
really wish I were in it
um there I fixed it
you do what you can
um so I'm not going to fully recount
John's illustrious
career but I do want to point out why
his work is is so revered many many
achievements certainly many
contributions
um but he was a key player in two major
debates both of which have been so
important and transformative for our
discipline one was the origin of birds
needed absolutely seminal work on on
archeopteryx and
um and and he was a major player in the
sort of the revolution in dinosaur
physiology and behavior drawing largely
on his work on deinonicus a dinosaur he
discovered and named and which really is
the model for the Raptors of Jurassic
Park
and so
um we're here to sort of in a sense
celebrate John ostrom's work and so what
I'd like to do today is show you how we
get inside the heads of dinosaurs if
we're interested in dinosaurs as living
breathing animals we do have to sort of
um look Beyond the Bones themselves to
see what the bones can tell us about the
soft tissues the muscles blood vessels
nerves brains skin the clothes and
animate the skeleton the the the the the
features that that
um in the biology that time has Stripped
Away
um really ultimately it comes down to
how do we go from this to this from a
pile of bones to a fully functioning
biological entity and really more to the
point what kind of science is involved
in reconstructing the biological
attributes of extinct animals
well where do we start
we start with bones in the ground which
we remove and carefully clean which we
may
um mount in in museums we still kind of
have a pile of bones though maybe
arranged in a more lifelike manner
in many cases the bones themselves hide
away their secrets within the Rock in
which they're entombed and I call all of
these dinosaurs here analog dinosaurs
because they live in real physical space
and you can touch them and smell them
and taste them and and I love analog
dinosaurs but there's a lot that you
can't do with them and so we've made the
the jump into the digital realm where
you can take a skull like this T-Rex
here and run it through a a CT scanner
at your local hospital or in this case
one of NASA's rocket engine cat scanners
and that step transfers that analog
dinosaur into the digital realm and once
it's in your computer you can spin it
around and look at from all angles which
is pretty handy because a lot of these
guys get pretty heavy but the real
advantage in all of this is that you can
look inside all of those secrets that
have been kept away from our eyes for
millions of years are now revealed that
Dusty old pile of bone sort of starts to
come alive brimming even dripping with
Biology
so if soft tissues are so important and
and dinosaurs fossils are just a
collection of Bones how do we get that
soft tissue information that is so
important well obviously we need to look
at animals that still have all of those
soft tissues intact and those are
animals living today
so here are what we call extant animals
so here is dinosaurs typified by T-Rex
of course
and where it fits into a phylogeny or
the Tree of Life birds are most closely
related Earth are in fact a kind of
dinosaur and then things like
crocodilians and turtles and and lizards
and mammals are more distantly related
but really the present is the key to the
Past
it's kind of a slogan but what it really
means is that if you're interested in
dinosaurs you can't just look at
dinosaurs you gotta have one foot in the
past but you got to have the other foot
firmly planted in in the present
and so our methods uh run from the the
classical to The Cutting Edge
we use such time-honored old-fashioned
techniques like the section and and
Vascular injection and sectioning uh uh
trying to understand
um uh the the structures of modern day
relatives of dinosaurs really trying to
give us ideas and information on the
relationships of the soft tissues to the
bones that we can then check for in the
dinosaurs and one thing I'll quickly
point out is that all the animals all
the modern day animals that we get in
are what are called Salvage specimens
Salvage carcasses that died somewhere
else for some other reason we're
euthanized and then we're donated uh to
our lab for research
but we also use the latest technique
technology with CT scanning to get
inside the heads of dinosaurs CT
scanning is an x-ray modality developed
for use in in hospitals and we do a lot
of scanning at hospitals but many
universities like Ohio University and
Yale have high resolution micro CT
scanners that are also very helpful for
us
uh so CT is actually a wonderful thing
so if you want to visualize bones and
teeth the hard tissues but one of the
problems with CT is that it's not so
great at visualizing soft tissues so if
we take this lovely little crocodile
skull or head here and run a slice
through it you can see that all the soft
tissue is basically just wind up being a
sort of indistinct gray we need some way
to enhance the contrast so we can
actually see what's going on in 3D so it
turns out that administering iodine has
been a game changer for the study of a
lot of this morphology because iodine
differentially binds to different soft
tissues such that we can now see it's
not indistinct gray we can see just
about everything it's really quite
remarkable the detail that we can get
what we don't see exactly everything
that we'd like to see because our lab is
also so interested in blood vessels the
blood vascular system and how blood is
shunted around the body and we'll talk
about this a fair amount as we go in
today so for example what we do is we
can take a carcass that was donated to
us of a pelican in this case and inject
its um we can use barium which is a
chemical that shows up on CT scans and
we can inject it into the arteries and
veins and then subject it to CT scanning
so if we look at some slices here
through this Pelican we can see that
we've got nice bright white arteries and
gray veins so we can distinguish between
arteries and veins you can see that the
uh the muscle and the bone is much less
dense in sort of a darker gray if we
look closer we can actually see that
we've got veins surrounded by arteries
as well as arteries within veins that's
really exciting for us because it opens
up the possibility of having some
physiological role here particularly
with regard to heat exchange and
shuttling heat and cool around the body
again this is something we'll talk about
today when we get to our dinosaurs
and so we've been using these techniques
for example
um uh our vascular techniques we're
starting to explore the physiological
significance of these uh using thermal
imaging and so in this case we were
actually following up on the Pelican
example we're able to actually show how
um blood that's cooled in the in the
pouch of the Pelican actually can be
routed back to the brain to help
moderate brain temperatures and so these
kinds of approaches wind up being
um important for us and so this is just
a summary slide showing the the various
kinds of of
techniques and visualizations that we
can do we still do lots of old school
dissection we do that all the time it's
absolutely essential but these new
techniques have been so important we
scientists often like to throw around
the term transformative particularly in
our grant proposals
um but CT scanning has really been
transformed transformative for the the
science of of anatomy and morphology and
how it functions
so
um how can these techniques to help us
understand soft tissues help us actually
flesh out dinosaurs Hollywood can just
make stuff up
um looking at you Jurassic World
um but as scientists we need testable
hypotheses grounded in the structure of
the fossils as well as their modern day
relatives well let's have a look and
focus on this long neck sauropod
dinosaur Diplodocus
so of course we start with the fossil
itself
but the fossils are often
distorted or they're missing parts or
they're broken whether by nature or by
human hands what we really want is the
actual pristine skull that was in the
animal's head uh when it was alive so
that we can build the soft tissues on
that this skull looks pretty nice and
and it is but it's been living under a
mountain for the past 150 million years
and just kind of beat up so what we can
do then is by CT scanning we can pull
that analog skull into a digital
environment once there's a computer
hopefully we can start to fix it to
reverse the ravaging effects of of time
that is we can then use computer
software like Maya or zbrush to correct
Distortion to replace missing bones to
fix broken uh broken broken elements
starting to bring that that thing back
into what we might call the skull that
the the the that the animal animal had
and this winds up being a key thing now
you may quibble about any of the
decisions that we made in in making this
this skull but given the vast uh
variation within the natural population
of Diplodocus 150 million years ago I'm
pretty sure there was a skull that
looked pretty much just just like this
in fact this skull is really no longer
cm1161 it's basically just Diplodocus at
this point and so now that we've got a
complete scale we can start to hang some
soft tissues on it so
um
if you so what we're going to do is sort
of try to understand how we can flesh
out this head and now if you think about
it within our heads there's sort of two
classes of soft tissues that we have
we've got those that are sort of sitting
within cavities like our brain or the
things within our nasal cavity and we
have things that span bones uh like the
jaw muscles well let's start with the
first one the things within bones
because those are a little easier so we
can take a skull I like Diplodocus it's
actually a different skull than the one
we just looked at
um and we can run it through a CT
scanner like we did here and then
digitally slice it
uh revealing a really nice cavity in the
back of the skull that's filled with
rock
we can then use software to digitally I
um digitally isolate or highlight
segment as the term we use in the in the
business here
um that structure that we now call a
brain endocast we then use the
information we gained and experience
gained from looking at the modern day
relatives of dinosaurs to figure out
what parts of that pertain to the brain
versus nerves versus blood vessels we
can do the same thing with our our our
our modeled
um Diplodocus and you can actually see
this is again based on numerous
specimens where we've we've looked at
not just that one specimen but every
specimen we could find
um we're constantly referring to things
like the specimens cast of them CT scan
data photographs the literature that
allows us to restore these things such
that now that we we can restore the
brain endocasted Diplodocus completely
and we can actually extract it view it
from from all angles and even 3D print
it if we so choose and so
um
if we think about some of these
well-constrained structures they include
what we just talked about which is this
brain endocast in the back there also
some other pretty well constrained
structures like a cartilaginous nasal
septum the same septum that we have like
somebody has a deviated septum it's the
same septum
um as well as this air sinus right in
there and also portions of things like
blood vessels and nerves that sort of
lie within grooves on the on the on the
on the bone or actually tunnel through
it in bony canals but we also have less
constrained structures these are the
harder ones to a certain extent like in
some of the blood vessels and nerves
actually pass through open space those
parts are a little harder for us to
reconstruct also things like the jaw
muscles that run from the skull down to
the lower jaw also things like the
eyeball and it's kind and the other
contents within the eye socket as well
as the airway and there's more things
that we could add in here and in fact
are but you can get a sense as to how
all these soft tissues actually share
space within the skull
um actually in all of these are all of
these ideas here all of these
soft tissues that you see here actually
constitute hypotheses that we can test
via a variety of of of of criteria for
example we use uh bony signatures the
osteological correlates these are things
like the scars that muscles leave or the
canals or grooves in the bones left by
blood vessels and nerves we can also use
phylogenetics and here we're we're
referring to the genealogical
relationships of organisms that tell us
something about the expected Anatomy for
example we'd expect this air sinus in
the front of the snout to be here and
these it be here because it's a shared
attribute of dinosaurs and their
relatives so we would expect that to be
there and finally packaging packaging
constraints wind up being really
important the fact that it's all got a
fit means that all of the different soft
tissue systems in a sense tell us about
themselves they tell us about each other
sort of a process of reciprocal
illumination
so using these kinds of things we can
start to flush these these animals out
a good example of packaging constraints
are in fact the jaw muscles
um
and this work actually wound up being
really important to us as we try to
understand the function of the feeding
apparatus and Diplodocus because as we
were doing this work one thing we
discovered is that we actually couldn't
get everything to fit we had a problem
particularly with the jaw muscles and so
it turns out we you know made all these
very careful in minute adjustments on
Physicians making sure they were right
but we wound up really having to adjust
the thicknesses of the muscles such that
they wound up being very thin straps and
a key thing to remember about this kind
of work is that in the real world
muscles actually bulge when they
contract and that's actually winds up
being a key factor when you're trying to
do this kind of work because in the real
world muscles can't be allowed to
intersect or overlap in the digital
world you can let things overlap in the
real world that's not going to happen
also what shouldn't happen in the real
world if a muscle bulges it shouldn't
cause the skull to explode
important safety tip
and and so
um that caused us to um adjust our
thicknesses even further which had some
pretty significant implications for for
the for the the biology of these animals
just a quick aside here to as a shout
out to some of the team that was
involved in helping us
um with the early phase of this visible
interactive dinosaur working our vid
Diplodocus this is about 10 years ago
and I'll point out that four of this of
the grad students in this in this photo
right here are now profess Anatomy
professors at Medical School
um and this woman right here in the
middle Kate Kirby O'Connell
um is now an animation supervisor at
Disney Studios
um and so she was she's done amazing
things
and so using these kinds of techniques
we've actually done more than just uh
Diplodocus and so we've actually
restored uh more or less full head
anatomy in a whole range of different
dinosaurs we've got some others that
aren't in this this image and it'll also
point out and acknowledge the role of my
long time research associate and
actually research collaborator on all
this Ryan Ridgely and my good friend for
for over 20 years who's helped me
um work through all this this kind of
work and so
all of these different in a sense to
flesh out all of these things it
actually winds up being quite a bit of
work it's very tedious process of
iterative hypothesis testing and making
all of these references to the structure
of the bones and the relationships of
the soft tissues all those bony
signatures but the reality is we can do
it but what's really exciting is what we
can do with it that is how we can use
these Restorations to start to explore
things like the function physiology and
behavior of these animals what we call
higher order inferences
um and an obvious one is one that we
just talked about which is more
realistic modeling of of the of of jaw
and muscle movements like just like we
saw here in Diplodocus and I pointed out
that our work on this sort of um uh
restoration of Diplodocus required us to
have really really thin uh muscles which
was very curious to us at the time Eric
snively was a postdoc in my lab and Eric
is really interested in engineering and
Engineering approaches and so he wanted
to have a look at this and so what he
did was he actually measured the lengths
and volumes of all of these jaw muscles
so we could calculate muscle forces and
what what he found was that uh the bite
he was really interested in using an
approach called finite element analysis
which is an engineering approach that
tells us something about stresses and
strains in skulls and actually tells us
something about bite force and bite
force is a very important parameter for
for for any animal really and so what
Eric found was that the the bite force
of Diplodocus was actually just a
quarter one-fourth of what we thought it
was before we did all this work and so
Eric's work has been very uh helpful
very important here is one of these um a
finite element analysis illustrations
showing uh an animation showing areas of
high stress and the hot colors showed
that where stresses are very high and
and that's going to make a have a big
impact on what it's going to mean for
bite force and so our study showed that
Diplodocus had a much weaker skull than
what we had thought in the past and in
the past we thought it had a pretty weak
skull and so these new findings are
impact our view on what the behavior and
biology of Diplodocus must have been
another project again this one was also
led by by Eric snively
involved looking at restoring lots of
the soft tissues in the head and the
neck of a Jurassic predatory dinosaur
called Allosaurus based on a famous
specimen known as as Big Al and what we
used was borrowing another engineering
approach something from robotics called
quantitative multi-body Dynamics
and so we reconstructed uh for example
things like the air sinuses and the
snout and the attachments of the of the
uh of the neck muscles and basically ran
all of these analyzes and cutting to the
chase one of the things we discovered is
that allosaurus's head and neck actually
had something called a low rotational
inertia that's jargon but what it means
is that um Allosaurus could move its
head around with a lot of flexibility
and control
we also found it was an unexpected
finding that there was an unusual
attachment of an of a neck muscle that
indicates that Allosaurus may have had a
sort of an unusual
um or different approach for removing
flesh from a carcass where it would
actually use sort of a tugging action
like we saw just there something that we
see the Falcons do today this a tug or
axial tearing rather than something like
a lateral Shake of the head which is
what alligators do and is in fact what
our studies showed that T-Rex did as
well so we're able to use these kind of
approaches to kind of drill down onto
some fairly fine-grained
um
um aspects of feeding behavior in in
this case
all right well let's actually transition
away from from uh feeding biomechanics
for a second and go back to physiology
uh one thing I mentioned before that
these
um uh these uh vascular injections allow
us to in a sense look at patterns of
heat flow because the blood vessels
actually shuttle uh blood around the
body to warm and cool certain areas this
is something we know from our own
experience on a really hot day we will
become flushed our skin will be turned
red as we shunt blood to the skin to
radiate heat
likewise what we saw just to remind you
of our Pelican here where we discovered
that there were venous blood that was
cooled in the pouch was routed to the
head to to moderate brain temperatures
and keep the animals from from
overheating and so these um uh vascular
injection approaches really played into
our dinosaur research in a big way with
the work of my former former doctoral
student Ruger Porter and his studies of
uh dinosaur vasculature and brain
Cooling and here's the problem and it's
very well known dinosaurs were big they
were ridiculously big in many cases what
that means is that they had a low
surface to volume ratio and how you can
Envision that is like a big pot of stove
or a big pot of chili on your stove
large things heat up and cool down very
slowly as opposed to like these little
dinosaurs you can see there on the right
which are sort of more like your a cup
of coffee that gets cold as soon as you
turn your back on it due to their high
high surface to volume ratios so
dinosaurs had these high heat loads they
would have been a big heat sink and one
consequence of that is that hot blood
from the core would rush to the head and
potentially damage the the heat
sensitive brain and sensory tissue is
located there
and so as a result dinosaurs must have
had some kind of physiological
mechanisms to protect and cool those
sensitive organs we know that in modern
day animals blood vessels form heat
exchangers and so ruger's project was
largely to try and identify sites of
heat exchange in these dinosaurs
just as our evaporation of our sweat on
a hot day
cools us down animals use evaporative
cooling
um just just as we do and so we targeted
three main sites of evaporative cooling
in the head that animals have including
the mouth or the oral region the nasal
region or nose
as well as the eyes and eyelids within
the eye socket or the orbit
as always what we do is we ground our
inferences in the um in the uh the
modern day relatives that we see here
and we did I don't know dozens and
dozens of injections of modern day
animals
um in all cases trying to document
um not just the blood vessels themselves
but also their bony signatures the the
the
osteological Coralis the grooves and
canals that we can then check for in the
dinosaurs so we can start to reconstruct
uh dinosaur vascular Anatomy as well
and so
um basically what we found is as an as
in modern day species today
um blood would have been cooled venous
blood would have been cooled in these
same three sites of of heat exchange and
the nose the mouth and in the eye socket
and sure enough what we found were
evidence of Rich vascular plexuses and
the nose and in the roof of the mouth
where venous blood would have been
cooled by evaporative cooling and then
routed back to the brain via
a variety of different routes and so
this information showed us that
majungasaurus and Diplodocus indeed
probably
more dinosaurs maybe all dinosaurs had
the vascular Machinery to help regulate
their brain temperature
um in a sense solving or addressing a
problem associated with their large body
sizes and so although it looks like all
of these dinosaurs
um probably had all these three sites of
of heat exchange
some dinosaurs or groups of dinosaurs
actually emphasize different blood
vessels they had different thermal
strategies
for example uh something like uh
Diplodocus and majungasaurus actually
seem to have a sort of a balanced
strategy meaning that all three sites of
of heat exchange actually uh seem to be
important whereas some actually
emphasize one site or another for
example a camarosaurus the large bodied
sauropod dinosaur really emphasized the
mouth the oral the oral site of heat
exchange whereas the armored dinosaur
you a placephilis here on the left
actually did the reverse and was very
much using its nose and nasal region as
as a as a heat heat exchanger an air
conditioner and so these kinds of
approaches have been very very helpful
um as a as a brief aside I'll point out
that
um actually in uh in 2020 National
Geographic did a major Roundup of
dinosaur research and they actually
featured this product project in a in a
two-page infographic right here and here
are our guys right here is U plus
cephalus and camarosaurus in the
jungasaurus
um and so it was pretty cool that they
did that in fact I really like their
title and so I stole it for my slides
don't tell them
cleverer than I am so
um uh kind of a similar kind of a
project was actually trying to
understand patterns of airflow through
the snouts of dinosaurs Ryan Ridgely and
I a number of years ago
did a project where we're pretty well
nailed down where all the air spaces
were within the snouts of a lot of
dinosaurs and in some something like
euplo kephalus this are you a
placephilis this ankylosaur had a really
unusual nasal cavity with all these
twists and turns in it
that's suggesting that ran right next to
all those blood vessels that we just
talked about suggesting a potential role
in in heat exchange and potentially even
metabolic physiology we also modeled
airflow with regard to the sense of
smell or oral faction as you did here in
T-Rex and
we like to think this was an advance but
this was 15 years ago we were basically
just drawing arrows
we're in a 3D virtual environment we
should be able to to model it
and so actually Jason Burke another
former PhD student in my lab wanted to
tackle this project
um using another engineering approach
called computational fluid dynamics and
I think our lab may have been one among
the first to actually start using a cfd
on animals and Jason's been very busy
over the years doing lots of of modeling
of airflow and lots and lots of
different kinds of animals and I'll
point out that actually just about all
of these are first the first time that
any bird has been had its airflow
modeled or reptile or extinct animal of
any kind if you look closely you can
actually see the air moving around in
there and it's actually telling us
something about the speed and one of the
things that we can see here that in all
these cases we get faster air flow in
the main Airway as it goes from the
nostril down into the throat and much
slower airflow so in the back part of
the nasal cavity where smelling takes
place it's been thought for some time
that these slower air speeds in the
olfactory chamber are in a sense allow
the olfactorate molecules there are
little particles of smell you might
think about smell as being particles but
there are little particles of smell that
find their their receptors and the
slower air speeds are thought to to to
make that easier and Jason's research
actually his modeling shows that um uh
very very nicely
so we wanted to apply this this um this
approach on an extinct animal in this
case and again Jason LED this project
and we this project focused on
pachycephalosaurs which are the Bony
headed dinosaurs in this case uh
stegosaurus pachycephalosaurs are
actually a great group to work on lots
of things that are that involve soft
tissues because they ossified so many
different kinds of soft tissues that
other kinds of dinosaurs didn't
so if we take the skull and slice it in
half we can of course see this big thick
bony Dome on top of its head that gives
these animals the name its name but also
what we can see is in the back part of
the nasal cavity right in here are
preserved unexpectedly
um a series of scrolled
portions of mineralized cartilage these
are something you would actually call
turbines turbinates because the the
scroll sort of look like the veins on a
turbine
and so they're in the the region where
spelling takes place so we call these
olfactory turbinates one thing we also
found was a ridge that runs right down
the main part of the nose right there in
the main Airway that almost certainly
had some kind of a turbinate attached to
it the key thing here is that that Ridge
right there is in the main Airway and so
any turbine in there would be a
respiratory turbinate and the signif
there is that respiratory turbinates
have been sort of
really thought to be important in in
metabolic physiology because
warm-blooded or endothermic mammals and
birds have those kinds of of structures
respiratory turbulence so
um turns out that we have all these
structures too
and so we can sort of see the turbulence
there in a skull in life those are
actually covered with a mucous membrane
in which case we call those Conkey and
these these conking and turbinates are
actually involved in warming and
humidifying and filtering The Inspired
air but also this is where a lot of the
heat exchange is going too recall this
is one of those three sites of heat
exchange along with the oral cavity and
the orbit now the mucosa is mucous
membranes are long gone and the fossils
that rots away quickly but we might be
able to get a handle on on the turbines
and so
um that was what we set out to do with
stegosaurus and we actually tested a
variety of hypotheses versus a series of
criteria and I'll just focus on one
Criterion because it's it's sort of
interesting
um in that there should be some amount
of olfactory airflow some air going back
into that olfactory chamber in
stegosaurus and the reason for that is
that we see this got really large
olfactory bulbs in the brain in other
words the neural part of the brain
that's actually associated with the
sense of smell and again there's also
those well-developed olfactory
turbinates so there should be olfactory
airflow the kicker was when we actually
ran the analysis in the absence of any
kind of terminate in that that main
Airway space there we actually had no
olfactory airflow in fact the inspired
air just completely bypassed the
olfactory region suggesting that there
must be some kind of turbine in there if
only to act as a baffle to direct air
towards that olfactory region
so we can sort of look at this the skull
right here again this is cut in half and
we can we do have evidence we have that
nice uh Ridge right there that's very
similar to the kind of turbulent ridges
we see in mammals and in Birds
um and so that gives us the opportunity
to in a sense build um well actually you
can see where that that Ridge right here
is to be sliced through the skull right
here you can see that Ridge that same
Ridge right in there in the fossil
and what we did then was to actually
model in a turbinate attaching to the
length of that
um
that that Ridge we actually modeled
multiple different sort of conformations
or shapes of that turbinate including
being scrolled or being branched which
we borrowed actually literally from a
turkey and a and an ostrich it turns out
that the um the branched conformation
the turkey
turbinet actually performed better
um but the reality is that we don't
really know what that turbinate looked
like because we just have the ridge but
it turns out that with the analysis it
doesn't really matter because any of the
confirmations we used actually restored
olfactory airflow and so what we can see
here is that
um the the presence of the ridge gives
us the general size and position of
where that turbinate is and the
computational fluid dynamics analysis
showed us that there must have been some
kind of turbinate in that position
regardless of what its shape is and it's
kind of interesting with by modeling
different shapes that the specific shape
doesn't really matter that much so there
are things that we can't know but what's
useful for us to try to figure out is
how much do we actually need to know and
so we know enough that there must be
something else going on in there and so
in the publication we talked about the
physiological implications of this what
it might mean for for you know
warm-bloodedness and metabolic
physiology but it was also we're also
really we're interested in highlighting
at least to us this this notion that's
kind of obvious in retrospect but
Overlook which is that turbines also
formed or performed the function of
acting as baffles to move air flow
throughout the nasal region
so stepping back and just looking at
this this is actually you know an animal
that lived during the Cretaceous and
we're doing some fairly refined
knowledge of or fairly refined studies
trying to understand how these animals
work and we can do that once we're in
this digital environment
well let's go back to
um uh the armored dinosaurs ankylosaurus
again if you recall I mentioned that U
plus cephalus had this long really
convoluted Airway sort of like the crazy
straw that the kids have if you remember
crazy straws
um and so
um we were interested in actually what
this might mean in terms of of of heat
exchange in terms of warming and
humidifying inspired air and at the same
time
um uh recapturing moisture and heat
during exhalation
and we had a great team to pull this
together again we had Jason Burke doing
the computational fluid dynamics and rug
reporter with his work on on the
vasculature
and this model right here shows uh one
of the results of this work which
actually shows a remarkably efficient
system for actually in fact warming the
air and humidifying on its way down to
the lungs
so if we look at um
this slide here which is a little
complicated this actually represents one
of the ways that we actually assessed
efficiency in this case we were looking
at the efficiency of reclaiming heat
um during when the animal exhales and
actually if we look at this image at the
top left right there that's basically
what the fossil gave us in a sense
that's the Bony bounded thing if we just
fill it up and look at that that's what
the the fossil looks like and that's
actually not bad that's hovering around
70 efficiency one cool thing about being
in in the digital environment is that we
can actually generate Anatomy that
nature never did and so this top middle
image right there is one where Jason
basically took out all the convolutions
and made the nasal cavity much shorter
such that the airway went from the
nostril down into the throat just like
we saw in stegosaurus and just like in
in us and you can see right there that
the efficiency plummets to less than 30
percent if you do that this one at the
bottom is sort of interesting this is
one where we said okay well let's keep
all the length and we'll just get rid of
all the convolutions just make it a long
straight narrow thing
um and what we can see there is actually
that's way better it's at about 60 it's
way better than the short Airway but not
quite what we see up with the fossil
that as preserved in the fossil Airway
which that tells us that the
convolutions actually make a difference
uh those the the convolutions probably
relate to vortices or vortexes of air
and as they go around those curves that
actually apparently makes a difference
on the top right there though that's one
where we actually went a step further
and actually restored the soft tissues
we actually put
um the mucous membranes back in and at
that point we actually the efficiency
soars up to 80 to around 80 80 plus uh
percent right there so these kinds of
approaches
allow us to in a sense do simulations
and experiments within a computer
environment that give us a a a a a
glimmer into how these animals may have
actually worked and and stepping back a
little bit one of the things that's sort
of interesting is that ankylosaurs like
um eoplacephalus don't actually have
turbinates like we saw in stegosaurus or
people in a whole bunch of of other
animals but what they may have actually
by having this long convoluted Airway is
um in a sense an alternate evolutionary
solution to the same physiological
problem a lot of things ultimately just
matter about surface area an expanding
surface area no matter how you you do it
also we can see how well
um Ruger Porter's work uh jived with
with Jason's work and that we can see
that these um uh blood vessels the the
veins would have actually been cooled by
evaporative cooling as they're going
past all of those
um the mucosa within those that
convoluted Airway and then that cool
blood routes back towards the brain to
help moderate brain temperatures
and I think John Ostrom would have loved
all this
um I think he would have um John was
actually a geologist but he was also a
hardcore anatomist as well and so
um going back to his doctoral
dissertation in 1961 that was looking at
these crazy crests on the heads of
duckbill dinosaurs like corythosaurus he
actually did a lot of work with modern
day animals so he was looking at things
like jaw muscles and brains and Airways
and animals that are around today so
that he could interpret his fossils
that's exactly what we do today we've
just got different tools we've got more
advanced tools to do that and John's
work has been absolutely foundational
for work that we've done
um sort of you know 21st century kind of
stuff looking at the um the structure
and development of these Airways and as
well as the brain in carythosaurus as
well as some of its other animals and
this is a good sort of lead-in to
another benefit of this
um these very uh visual 3D
3D Restorations is that it's a really
way a good way to reach out to the
public with our science because they're
so visible and so easy to understand uh
again uh in the the 2020 National
Geographic they did another
um infographic on our work in this case
of a cousin of corythosaurus called uh
hypocrisaurus looking at the airway but
also the brain and sensory systems and
are also our work on Parasaurolophus
another cousin of of corythosaurus uh
will actually be appearing soon in a in
a TV documentary uh devoted to some some
other things and that picture at the
lower right there shows me holding the
3D prints of the skull and Airway of
parasaurolophus which probably would
have just been an unbelievable thrill
for John Ostrom to have been able to do
something like that
so in summary
um uh the work of of people like John
Ostrom remains as vital today as as it
ever has
um and we're just in a sense building on
it the modern technology has not
replaced it or cast it aside rather
um we're using it as a foundation for us
um to actually use these Technologies to
actually start to
understand the biology of dinosaurs by
basically putting them back together in
a computer and at the same time that
really gives us a new opportunity to
reach out to the public and talk to them
about science just like we're doing
right now
and thanks for your attention today
I'll just quickly point out I took this
I took this photo this morning when I
was in working in the collections over
in over in the Peabody Museum
all right thanks so much Larry
um so we will have a question answer
session uh
for about maybe say 10 minutes now and
what's going to happen is I'll call on
people and if you wait until someone
runs up to you with a microphone so
everyone can hear the question that
would be great okay let's go yes over
here
please
come in
yes
thank you very much just wondering it's
not directly to do what you're doing but
you must have thought about it
what about intelligence can you say with
any
definitive for this that certain species
were more intelligent than others
because of this and that sure yeah yeah
the question was what can we say about
intelligence in these in these in these
animals and actually I've got a I've
been studying um uh brains and dinosaurs
for a long time we've got a major Grant
that's looking at cognition in deep time
and intelligence is a is a sort of a
difficult thing to to do and a lot of
cognitive biology prefer the term
cognition as to how how capable are
animals of solving problems in learning
and things like that we colloquially
would call that smart and the reality is
there are differences among dinosaurs
um in that in that capacity
we always tend to think that animals
just need to be smart enough
um uh and a key factor in that is that
brains are very expensive organs uh
brains actually cost a lot of energy
that we take in and so animals very
often need to in a sense evolutionarily
fine-tune their their brain size so that
they're not in a sense wasting energy on
cognitive abilities or neural processing
that they don't need and so we see
animals like
um like T-Rex and other predatory
dinosaurs tend to have relatively large
brains because they're doing a lot of
neural processing to be Predators
whereas something like Diplodocus uh
plus it's heart
um
Sora is going there has really quite a
small brain but the dude was gigantic
and it was just eaten plants that aren't
moving and so it's cognitive
requirements we're significantly less
and so the the notion of dinosaur
intelligence is something that that our
broader team is actually a multinational
team is actually working on so thank you
for that question
up here talk back
way back
saw your hand up this whole time
are you like holding a Deinonychus over
there yeah yeah that's a Dynamics same
dynamicus as John Ostrom right there yep
and that's a dynamicus foot right there
with the killing claw or a second I
thought that was like velociraptor right
it's it's very similar to Velociraptor
Velociraptor
um in the movies is like this big in
real life it was about this big
before about Hollywood I watched the
franchise a lot
you you and me you and me both dude
you can come see that Deinonychus when
the museum reopens he's here
okay let's see
how about
the back of the front row here
do you use to determine how
strong a jaw muscle to like help
determine how strong a jaw muscle would
be
do you use whether there would be a
carnivore or a
um
well word yeah herbivore bad and that
that word that I can't pronounce yet all
right okay well I normally can't but
okay
um because the carnivores might need
more jaw muscle to
um to actually tear the flesh off
whereas the
um herbivores wouldn't need to do that
yeah that's a great question so the
question was well what kind of muscle
force does it take to be a predator or
an herbivore and the answer
um as is so true in much of life is it
depends
um and it depends on what kind of a
carnivore you are and what kind of an
herbivore you are so for example
if your T-Rex and adult T-Rex and you
are biting bones you need big powerful
muscles to to actually crack through
those bones if you are dionicus
your skull is probably adapted more for
removing flesh using other ways to to
kill the animal and dynamicus is
actually a fairly delicate animal in
many ways and so it was probably not
cracking bones something like Allosaurus
we talked about Allosaurus and how it
was actually pulling back and in that
case when it was removing flesh from the
bone it was actually just holding on
with its teeth and then muscles that
were actually working were the neck
muscles to pull that back same thing
with some of the plant eaters something
like the ploticus right here basically
its teeth are kind of a joke they're
just these little um they look like
little crayons that are jammed in the
front of its face that were probably as
sort of as rakes or something to strip
branches off they were not chewing and
so they had relatively like super weak
jaws and bite force whereas there's
other dinosaurs other plant eaters that
have really powerful bites and
particularly if there's animals that are
doing things like biting repeatedly like
chewing or cracking seeds that requires
a big big jaw muscles a cardinal at your
feeder has really big jaw muscles
because it's cracking seeds whereas a
sparrow at your feet or doesn't because
it's just picking up little little seeds
and chucking them down so it depends but
it's a great question thank you
oh bottom here in the blue
how do you figure out how to do all of
that yeah
that may be the best question we got how
do we figure out how to do all that
I spent a lot of time explaining that to
that thing that says NSF up there
that's the funding agency but that's a
great question I don't mean to make
light of it because actually it's it's
kind of hard to do all this these things
and there's lots and lots of steps and
you saw that I had a lot of people that
I work with I work a lot with with
graduate students and undergraduate
students I've even had high school
students working in my lab and postdocs
and we work as a team and we often do
different parts of it like you saw I had
one person that was working really hard
on blood vessels and trying to figure
out where they went another person that
was trying to figure out how airflow
works
and so all of these team members get
together and they and they work and they
work as a team but it is hard and it
takes us a while sometimes to actually
come up with these things thank you
that's a great question
at least I have it right next to you
no
um you talked uh about uh you a
placephilis and it's a very complicated
nasal passages now in in more recent
days I've seen uh sort of interesting
speculative reconstructions of
uplocephalus and similar ankylosaurs
with like nasal air sacs attached to the
nostrils that will inflate and possibly
like make a sound to communicate
um your thoughts on that is that
plausible sure yeah so the the question
was
um some people have actually suggested
that some dinosaurs could have had
inflatable sacks that are coming out of
their nose
um which sounds pretty crazy
um but animals do crazy things
um and so I mean what euplocephalus does
without that is pretty crazy so if your
poseph was had inflatable nose sacs that
would be um maybe right in line for that
animal the reality is some of these
things are pretty hard for us to get at
the person that actually presented the
notion of that for um I think like
triceratops and its relatives a
ceratopsian
um I'm not sure he was I think he was
being a little Whimsical when he did
that but the fact of the matter is
um inflatable display organs
um are used all the time in the animal
kingdom
um I don't know if you've heard the
frogs out yet but you'll get the peepers
and they'll be actually doing in many
species it's actually brightly colored
uh there are things like elephant seals
and hooded seals that actually have
inflatable nose bags that come off of
their their their
apparently the females just love it
um
no accounting for Taste but um and so
could some of these dinosaurs have it
the answer is maybe and those are the
kind of questions that actually we are
trying to get at one of the things we've
discovered over the course of time is
that a lot of and sort of in some
respects my basic job has become is
where is the limit of what we can know
yeah it turns out a lot of the really
interesting things are like right out
there they're just beyond the limits of
what we can know what's interesting is
the technology like CT scanning and all
these other techniques around boom all
of a sudden we've got some new
techniques that we can that we can start
to know more than what we thought and
also just making the right comparisons
actually starting to look at we've
actually dissected hooded seals and
elephant seals because we have actually
are interested in that in that question
I have come to learn to Never Say Never
about life
um
because life just evolves all of these
different kinds of of organisms
thank you that's a good one
let's go uh
at least I haven't you're not all around
uh thanks so I guess something I'm
wondering about
um we know that dinosaurs I think at
least became warm-blooded over time I'd
imagine from a heat exchange standpoint
those would be
you know kind of different heat exchange
problems when you're dealing with a
cold-blooded creature versus a
warm-blooded one you see any like
evidence of
um changes in sort of the heat exchange
efficiency over time
well it's
um so the question was with the
evolution of warm-bloodedness or
endothermy
um you know would that occur over time
and what would we see changes in that
it's a great question it's a difficult
one but one that we've thought a lot
about
and often it's not so much over time
often it's within different groups
different groups will often have
different strategies
um and so the reality is it's really
hard to be
warm-blooded like we are I mean it's
actually hard to maintain uh body
temperature at at a peak rate and
there's lots of costs that go around
with that uh like breathing fast we
breathe faster than cold-blooded animals
and that's actually a lot of these
things that we're looking at in terms of
like reclaiming heat and water it's
because we breathe really fast and you
can actually dehydrate yourself when you
breathe too fast
um
and so
um we are actually indeed trying to look
at those those structures what's
interesting is that a lot of these um we
think about Hot Blooded dinosaurs a lot
of the things we're looking at are
things that are because dinosaurs are
too hot blooded in other words
endothermia makes some of these things
worse if you're a big dinosaur like
Diplodocus or any of these guys where
you're just a giant heat sink with the
sun coming down on you heating your
heating heating you up you're going to
be hot whether you're generating heat
internally like a warm blood you know an
endotherm does
um you're going to be hot anyways and so
these kinds of of of physio we call them
physiological devices things that you
can use to in a sense deal with these
heat problems are going to be true for
so many of these dinosaurs what's
interesting is we find evidence of a of
a pretty legit nasal uh a respiratory
turbinate in this little um uh stegos
which is right down here which doesn't
have the big overheating problem if
anything that guy would get chilly
um from time to time it was cold and so
there's a decent chance of something
like that
um would have had Endo if it were
endothermic
um it would have had the Machinery to
actually help deal with that
okay all right we're getting close to uh
past 10 after now and with great
apologies I think we're gonna have to
cut it off
um
thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]